[Music]  why is everybody so surprised about the  rather unorthodox policies coming out of  the White House at the moment you know  travel bans tariffs trade wars for me it  was obvious from the very beginning if  the leader of the free world doesn't  know how to wear a tie we have a serious  problem have a look this one's too long  this one's too long this one's too long  this one's too long  where does he buy these oh hang on did  you see that is that tape okay mr.  president let me grab you by the tie  here you do have a length issue the tip  of your tie can touch the top of your  belt buckle never ever shall it descend  any further into the nether regions and  there is no alternative fact also if you  wear your tie of the correct length the  small bit the thin bit will be long  enough to fit in the keeper loop in the  back that's what it's for  and no more taping up you have two more  minutes in the morning to maybe alienate  another Ally I'll never mind you're  welcome  [Music]